you see this title belt right here
tonight we get to go to wwe live we're
gonna get to go backstage it's gonna be
awesome content but i'm kind of pissed
because quite frankly this is the
perfect example of stuff that should go
on corridor and niko keeps saying how oh
this should go on sam and nico and no
it's not
[Music]
this is a work thing
nico and jake here on the floor of wwe
raw
this world for us
yeah our friend john carl
happened to have worked at the wwe in
the past and he invited us backstage to
meet some of the wrestlers to see how
the show's run and to watch some sweet
wrasslings
hey it's that time of the year again
fourth of july most americans favorite
holiday
we're gonna go light up some fireworks
we happen to have some
around don't worry about it
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know actually we can't show
these
this sounds like freaking like social
network
doesn't it
what is this it's uh casey's
cool little prototype for
uh the score for lifeline
it's kind of
uh it's kind of the labor of the last
few months here of trying to figure out
some vibes and sounds and themes
let's let's have some boo booms because
it's the fourth of july oh cool
ready for deployment
trying to go on the roof
artillery shells
yeah so
uh you have to blur out the the ones
that we showed they're perfectly legal
that's exactly why no one can see it can
you we can blow that right jake what's
this
that's 2 000 ladyfingers what's a lady's
finger it's a little it's a little it's
like a mini black cat they're harmless
how do you launch this i said i gotta
find a fixture for my flag cape
nico what's your favorite firework in
the world my favorite firework in the
world is a black powder charge
underneath a ziploc bag gasoline
i almost killed my great uncle once i
used to have a
stone cold steve austin t-shirt my dad
didn't let me watch wrestling in junior
high and i hid it in my locker at school
and i was wearing it on the same day i
got suspended for fighting
i ditched it in the bathroom so he
wouldn't get mad at me we're here to see
some of the greatest athletes of the
world beat up on each other it's gonna
be great dude walking into the curtains
like from backstage like holy [ __ ] this
is what it's like it's pretty cool nico
if you could be
a wrestler of any name what would your
name be nicholas maximus i was gonna say
nico the destroyer so that's pretty
close i'd be jawbone the villain javon's
pretty good yeah
big bob
all right let's do an intro the real the
real work of art here is the show the
lighting the music the camera there's a
guy running around down there he's been
running around since the start of this
match with a steady cam broadcasting it
live well a bunch of
wire monkeys are constantly
running his wires so he doesn't trip on
him
[Music]
this is your first show that's my first
show there's so much entertainment it's
insane alex loves wrestling alex what
has it been like being back here
backstage well i gotta see the baller
brand in action so that was amazing
i don't know a couple of times you like
looked at me like
it wasn't reverence
yeah it wasn't like uh
admiration it was kind of like you
looking at me like
like there's something wrong with me
like i have something on my face
i'm sorry
i mean i'm not aggravated but i'm just i
want to know like why why
the last couple of times you like stood
there like this and you you like cut
your eyes there
i think it was just the fact that i was
holding the belt see
i think i think you're gonna take all
the time i kind of think you need to get
this
somebody else need to ask a question
because i'm done
[Music]
be sure
that you can whoop them
i was like
all
in this right if you can't go from here
to there i don't consider myself to be
the best
but i know i love what i do and i'm good
at what i do and
um you know i think that we should be
giving more credit
it takes hours
for our crews to just set up we do a
full feature movie every week
just be able to go in and out like that
day and week in week out and maintain
that kind of athleticism is i think very
underappreciated i appreciate y'all time
man but i'm gonna have to roll out
thank you much i if i made you pee a
little bit i'm sorry
busy being productive but i'm just doing
my prudent gesture letting you know
we're about to blow some stuff up on the
roof
just in case you want to partake and buy
one stuff up i mean we have a big crate
of fireworks and it's almost fourth of
july
well i mean it is the fourth of july it
is the fourth of july you're correct i
am
extraordinarily busy but you know i i
think a few minutes just freed up
dude that's like the scene in saving
private ryan
see yeah
[Applause]
this one i'm not going early i don't
care what goes on my hand yeah
you know what's scarier than spiders
they're designed
they're designed for kills
this is gonna be a good one
gotta get the perfect timing
wild horse you take the stick and you
break it a bunch like that oh god
oh that's way too early niko
got a classic wild horse right there
[Music]
go look and see what smells so good
[Music]
hmm
i think i might slide out the stick
[Music]
one more time at some point
[Music]
[Music]
i'm done
[Music]